we're gonna move on to this
never-before-seen video from the jussie
Smollett hate crime case shows what
appears to be a noose around the empire
actors neck this video from a Chicago
police body camera was taken inside
smollett's home in January at the time
when he told police he was attacked it's
part of nearly 1200 files including more
than 90 hours of footage all newly
released by the department hadrian
adea's has the evidence that police say
proves that the attack was actually a
hoax police body camera video shows the
moment officers first arrived at justice
Millette apartment after the actor
claimed he'd been attacked
Smollett still has what appears to be a
noose around his neck
Smollett told police he was assaulted by
two masked men yelling racist and
homophobic slurs for more than three
weeks at least 24 detectives searched
for the two men and investigated
smollett's claims they eventually
reached this conclusion well let paid
$3,500 to stage this attack and drag
Chicago's reputation through the mud in
the process police say Smollett paid
brothers Abel and Ola esand I wrote has
staged the attack because he was angry
over his salary newly released video
showed the brothers on their way to the
scene of the attack and their arrests at
Chicago's O'Hare Airport less than a
month later the brothers told police
Smollett paid them to conduct the attack
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one
Smollett who's maintained his innocence
was arrested and later charged with 16
felony counts for lying to police
charges that were later dropped by the
Cook County State's Attorney's Office
stirring up massive protests in March we
spoke to state attorney Kim Fox who
defended the decision it's a nature of
this case suggested that he was eligible
for an alternative prosecution
there's eligible that's an optional you
also could have moved forward and tried
to go to trial with him we could have
the backlash against state attorney Kim
Fox continued long after her office
dropped the charges against Smollett a
judge has ordered a special prosecutor
to investigate the handling of the case
which could lead to more charges against
Smollett Anthony all right Adriana thank
you